habían mantenido una incómoda Alianza
desde el golpe de 2021 pero en la
rivalidad entre el jefe de estado de
facto de Sudán y su adjunto ha estallado
tras las tensiones sobre cómo debían
integrarse sus respectivas fuerzas
queremos construir unas fuerzas armadas
que respeten las normas de los regímenes
democráticos
demografía el general Abdul fatal ese
jefe del ejército regular soldado de
carrera del norte de Sudán que ascendió
en el escalafón bajo el gobierno de tres
décadas de Omar alguacil en 2019 prestó
juramento como líder interino de Sudán
para dirigir el país hacia la democracia
tras el derrocamiento de albahachir pero
en octubre de 2021 disolvió el consejo
conjunto militar civil en ese momento
contaba con el apoyo de Mohamed hamanda
galo más conocido como demetti vino de
origen más Humildes como comerciantes de
camellos pero ahora es uno de los
hombres más ricos de Sudán jefe de
estado adjunto y comandante del grupo
paramilitar fuerzas de apoyo rápido
soy un simple beduino que creció al
margen de Sudán y no recibió nada de mi
país salvo violencia
[Música]
que paramilitar Que formó tras alzarse
en armas en la guerra de darfurt ha
desempeñado un papel destacado en la
política de Sudán durante diez años
primero como Aliado cercano del
presidente albair antes de ayudar a
derrocarla en 2019
cada persona debe ejercer sus derechos
Si la gente no ejerce sus derechos no
avanzaremos
se han disputado el apoyo internacional
desde que llegaron al poder mientras que
meti se ha Aliado con Arabia Saudita al
burján ha normalizado las relaciones con
Israel y ha apelado repetidamente a su
vecino Egipto para que le garantice su
apoyo la rivalidad entre los dos hombres
ha saboteado de las aspiraciones
populares a la democracia y a
desestabilizado un país que haya sufrido
un colapso económico